and yeah he wants this game to last
forever
it's like for him like you know like
having you taking a bath yeah after a
tough day
he's pushing he's like he's in the bath
and he's like you add some soap
yeah there he is i think some soap
yeah i don't know but ian doesn't want
to do this he's like okay get out of
here
i'll try tomorrow this is not it
yeah and that's it we have the first
result of the day
malcolm was doing his middle finger my
magic there
he says that he should have gone crazy
seven didn't see how to stabilize
yeah but he's saying maybe you're right
so we have only one game left
yeah it will be very difficult for atl
tomorrow
uh it's almost impossible to be honest
yeah i can't imagine as well
but miracles do happen i'm really
wondering what approach he will like
will he play
something will he also like will he try
to avoid
uh you know avoid
any simplification or will he just hope
the muppets will play for a win
but what do you think which uh opening
magnus will choose
because it's about magnus yet